das genial heftig mit dem kopf so
richtig lecker wirklich
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt's ein ganz
besonderes rezept und richtig coole
neuigkeiten bleibt auf jeden fall dran
wenn sie erfahren möchte ich glaube da
freuen sich ganz ganz viel aus sich die
community auf jeden fall machen wir ein
job tristano baic im glas perfekt für
gäste perfekt wenn ihr nicht viel zeit
haben oder einfach nur so leckeres
schlemmen möchte ohne ganz viel aufwand
ich habe jetzt hier zwar eine
küchenmaschine aber ihr dürft natürlich
auch euer handrührgerät verwenden dass
das hier gar kein problem
ich mache so dass ich jetzt direkt
starte und euch wie immer die ganz
genauen mengenangaben unten in die
infobox reinschreiben dann könnte es
nämlich einfach screen schotten und
einkaufen gehen vielleicht sogar bei
kaufland dieses video ist zwar kein
placement oder kein werbe video aber
vielleicht kann ich die neuigkeit nicht
direkt schon groppen ich halte es nicht
aus die haselnuss creme gibt in allen
kaufland filialen und zwar haben wir uns
nämlich überlegt weil auch nach der
letzten aktion da gab es ja wirklich nur
ganz kurz und den meisten filialen weil
sie wirklich schon binnen eines tages
wenn überhaupt stunden ausverkauft
selbst ich habe hier in der umgebung gar
nichts mehr ich wollte natürlich auch
gegen und schauen wie liegen ihnen so
eine filiale die cremes habe ich selbst
nichts mehr abbekommen ich meine jetzt
nicht unbedingt kaufen aber ich würde
mir anschauen und weil es so beliebt bei
euch ist und die hazel cream auch so gut
bei euch ankommt haben uns gedacht die
wird jetzt dauerhaft in allen kaufland
filialen gelistet in ganz deutschland
also ihr könnt einfach in eure nächste
lieblings filiale gehen und sie euch
direkt mitnehmen ich hoffe es freut euch
ich konnte wirklich nicht mehr aushalten
ich habe ein rezept für den kaufland
kanal gedreht eine richtig leckere bueno
torte die verlinke ich euch am ende des
videos da könnt ihr auch gerne noch mal
raufgehen wenn ihr lust habt eine
leckere torte mit geht's weiter mit
meinem rezept steht für die kalte
schlagsahne in meinem schüssel und ich
nie mit extra kein sand fest dazu ich
möchte nämlich dass das richtig schön
cremig bleibt und gar nicht so fest wird
aber könnte aber auch schon mascarpone
braunen zucker dazugeben wer kein
braunen zucker da hat kann auch ganz
normalen weißen nehmen aber er passt
einfach geschmacklich jetzt ein bisschen
besser und dann schlage ich das ganze
erst mal langsam damit es sich verbindet
und dann werde ich einfach immer
schneller mit der geschwindigkeit so
dass es ein bisschen dicker und ein
bisschen fester wird und zum schluss
ruhig noch schmandt unter
den schmand wie gesagt nur ganz kurz
unter rühren quark wird jetzt an der
stelle nicht so gut passen wegen der
säure ihr könnt aber den schmand zum
beispiel auch durch creme fraiche
ersetzen das funktioniert hier auch
wunderbar und jetzt kommt natürlich die
hazel cream zum einsatz übrigens waren
hier ganz viele die schmeckt nach vail
aber auch macht otto weil ich finde sie
schmeckt so ein bisschen mehr nach
rottweil das so intensiv schmeckt sind
gerade bei warmen temperaturen sowie
heute ist es schon also das ist schon
sehr sehr cremige krems ist er ein
brotaufstrich aber meistens löffelt man
sehr weg und oder verpackt das irgendwie
und gerade bei warmen temperaturen
schaut mal das ist schon richtig cremig
und es cooler bei dieser creme ist auch
wenn ihr die jetzt in den kühlschrank
tun würdet oder ich mache ja auch
manchmal so eine haselnuss glasur dann
wird es im kühlschrank wiederum super
fest damit kann man so viel machen aber
auch super aufs brot nur ich frag mich
wirklich ihr könnt immer schreiben wer
von euch gönnt sich das wirklich auf dem
brot und wer macht er so desserts damit
schreibt mir das mal die kommentare das
würd mich mal interessieren
[Musik]
ich habe mir die creme jetzt noch in
einen spritzbeutel umgefüllt damit dies
gleich einfacher befüllen kann und ich
keine sauerei habe und jetzt könnt ihr
euch entscheiden nehmt ihr zum beispiel
löffelbiskuits oder wie ich nehme heute
am martini und ihr könnt sie halt
entweder in milch trinken dann werden
sie nach einer weile im kühlschrank
schön weich das mache ich jetzt wie von
42 sekunden eintunken und dann quasi in
ein glas geben einfach auf den boden die
mache ich jetzt 34 stück von rheine mit
dem boden einmal komplett bedeckt ist
dann habe ich noch so kleine ja das sehe
ich bisher gläser und da habe ich mir
gedacht da mache ich die variante der
nämlich einfach die american ii und den
händen einfach ein bisschen zerbröseln
dann bleiben sie ist nämlich schön
knackig und eigentlich funktioniert
beide varianten also welche jeder
verwendet oder macht ist komplett euch
überlassen schön wäre nur wenn man das
wirklich abwechselnd schichtet also
immer mal wieder ein paar martini und
dann die haselnuss creme lebenskraft
vorbereitet haben und wenn ihr mögt
könnt ihr auch noch ein paar jobs
dazwischen tun ich überlege ob ich da
wirklich nur oben als deko giottos nehme
weil wie gesagt diese creme inhaltlich
sehr viele an giotto und daher fand ich
das ganz passend
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die mini des jahres habe ich jetzt schon
vorbereitet da habe ich mir gedacht okay
dann öffnet man eher so creme und unten
kommt man dann auf diamantina oben habe
ich es ist eigentlich ein plural amerika
ich glaube da war irgendwas mit einfach
und so ich weiß es nicht mehr auf jeden
fall habe ich oben drüber auch noch ein
bisschen haselnuss coke hand gegeben bei
den großen bisher das mache ich jetzt
hier auf die zweite schicht auch noch
mal am martini und dann habe ich mir ich
werde doch noch cottbus mit 1 bauer ich
finde einfach so lecker ich habe jetzt
gerade schon halbiert und werde dann
gleich nach der weiteren creme schicht
schön außen einfach nur die halbierten
jobs sind noch mal hin platzieren und
dann noch mal mit creme abschließen und
auch mit toto und leckerem haselnuss
krokant dekorieren und dann sind sie
auch schon fertig ihr könnt sie
praktisch direkt servieren bei denen
würde ich sagen dadurch dass wir den
milch gepumpt haben dass die gern zwei
stunden im kühlschrank und ansonsten
funktioniert es aber auch wenn ihr das
am vortag vorbereitet dann habt ihr zum
beispiel keinen stress wenn ihr am
nächsten tag gäste bekommt
[Musik]
so ich dekoriere jetzt wirklich nur noch
zu ende einfach wie auch bei den mini
desserts giotto und haselnuss krokant
wenn ihr könnt ihr natürlich auch noch
früchte mit einbauen gerade jetzt wo
saison ist kann ich mir auch erdbeeren
ganz gut vorstellen und ja ansonsten
freue ich mich einfach über die gute
nachricht dass die creme jetzt überall
und natürlich auch dauerhaft zu kaufen
ist weil es war ja wie gesagt letztes
jahr nur eine aktion und danach habe ich
sehr viele nachrichten bekommen ja in
der und der filiale gibt es die gar
nicht und viele wussten gar nicht dass
es nur eine aktion ist und ja umso
schöner dass wir jetzt alle bekommen
können wir waren ja auch bei der ernte
dabei und wir konnten ja dort auch alles
nach unseren wünschen also die rezeptur
ist ja meine eigene wir konnten alles
selbst bestimmt und daher bin ich auch
froh dass sie einfach mal probieren
können vergleicht auch gerne mal schaut
einfach mal an alle die noch nicht
probiert haben das sind nicht mehr so
viele wie ihr sie findet und schreibt
mir dann natürlich euer feedback hier
unten in die kommentare
ich hoffe ich schaffe es dieses jahr
auch wieder zu ernte das war anders und
mein größter wunsch dass wir einfach
wieder dabei sind die haselnuss felder
die menschen dort ist es einfach ein
traum und otto ist sowieso ein traum es
ist nämlich direkt an der
schwarzmeerküste wo die leckersten und
aromatisch ist eine haselnuss herkommt
das klingt immer so aus wenn ich dann
aber es ist fakt und das sind einfach
erstklassige haselnüsse in unserer
haselnuss creme wir sind doppelt
geröstet kein palmöl keine zutaten nicht
aussprechen könnt das ist für mich immer
das allerwichtigste und ja ansonsten
werde ich euch den tests ist
wahrscheinlich so auf instagram film
haben sich nämlich gerade im shop und
macht ein paar produktfotos das kann
noch ein bisschen ziehen ich glaube ich
werde euch im test ist nicht gleich so
ein bisschen amateurhaft einbinden und
ansonsten entlasse ich euch aus diesem
video ich wünsche euch noch einen
wunderschönen tag und ganz viel freude
beim nachmachen und dann sehen wir uns
auch beim nächsten release eure ki
[Musik]
es folgt ein professioneller tastings
von hansa rostock
ich freue mich auf seine kritische und
ehrliche
schnell bewährt also ich muss mich
gedreht das hat die sorge geht deswegen
habe es mitbekommen was ist jetzt
gemacht wird so kurz tagen so gemacht
hast also ein sie sich kurz vorweg sagen
das ist doch dass teile in der hand
zwei davon habe ich weggehauen das ist
in der hand hat das große ja davon habe
ich weggehauen ich habe selber so klein
offenbach lucia die brücke das ist ein
motto dessert mit unserer hefel queen
war das geniale heftig mit dem kopf so
richtig lecker wird du musst mal rein in
die schichten was du was ich dann noch
vom ja deswegen abgesagt so habe ich
eben dann auch geschaufelt wo das jetzt
zwei desserts das ist so ein keks dran
aber es ist
genau das möchte man dass am ende das
große wirkung ich bin mir gesagt die
öffnet am maritim machen und nicht mehr
aufgesucht ja
ich hab nur geschaufelt ohne ende so
gewesen unter
leute die creme diessenhofen brotsuppe
zum backen geeignet und auch genau für
sowas besteht keine pflicht ist es
perfekt die krise gekriegt begibt
defekte süße ab defekte haselnuss
geschmack und richtig lecker wirklich
mega abzukaufen einkaufen erklärt uns
und und ist dauerhaft dauer ja deswegen
mache ein bisschen besser nochmal die
regale leer stehen damit kaufen sagt
woche mehr chris ich gern gemacht ich
habe es zusammen hätten
[Musik]